can you think of possible trajectories
how this
FTX SPF Saga ends
and which one do you hope for do you
hope that SBF goes to jail
that's the individual and in terms of
the investors and the customers what do
you hope happens and what do you think
are the possible things that can happen
so hey yeah I definitely think SPF
should go to jail
um for nothing else for a semblance of
Justice the facsimile of Justice to
occur for all the investors
um I also think there are people
probably several steps down the chain
that probably knew at least Caroline
Ellison you can have questions about
sort of their you know Dan Friedberg who
I'd love to talk about as well
um there were a lot of people in that
room who I think knew I think we do so
much of like the one guy is All To Blame
let's throw everything at him when
clearly this was a company-wide issue so
everyone who knew I think should face
the same punishment which I think should
be jail for all of those people
um
in part to send a signal to anybody that
tries this kind of stuff in the future
yeah absolutely I mean one of the big
things that you saw like okay take a
microcosm of all of this action and just
look at like the influencer space right
there's a ton of deals that were done
that I've covered Ad nauseam about
influencer finds out they can make a lot
of money selling a crypto coin the first
thing they wonder is am I going to get
caught
if I do this is there a consequence and
if the answer is no then it's a pretty
easy decision as long as you don't like
have any moral scriptures about it which
apparently none of them did or a lot of
them did and I should say
so
as soon as somebody steps in and
regulates that math changes and all of a
sudden there's a self-interest reason to
not go do the bad thing so for example
and I can give a concrete example of
this
there was a nft the first ever nft sort
of like
official indictment or the doj released
this press release that they're charging
these guys who ran a nft project that
they didn't follow through on their
promises they made all these promises
lied and then ran away with the money
first ever consequence for anyone in the
nft space that day that that press
release came out I saw several nft
um projects come back to life from the
dead
why because all those Founders are
freaking out and they realized we
scammed people we have to go at least
make make it look like we're doing the
right thing right even just so that's on
the optic side but there's also tons of
people who now go oh the basically law
enforcement is on the scene we can't do
the same thing so there is a very
pragmatic reason to for this punishment
it's very much just because people work
it into their math of should I commit
fraud and the last several years have
been very
um sort of has been like a little bit of
a nihilistic landscape where no one was
getting punished and so there's this
question of you're almost an idiot if
you didn't take the deals
um so I think it's really important
extremely important for kind of law
enforcement to play a role regulation to
play a role to make it harder to commit
those crimes and if you commit those
crimes there's actual real world
punishment for it
to your point about like what's going to
happen to the investors I think that was
kind of your question
it's tough because the if the money's
not there the money's not there I mean
there's going to be the guy they got the
Best in Class guy it's the guy who ran
the dissolving of Enron so I mean I
can't imagine someone better equipped to
run a complicated corporate fraud like
dissolution but
yeah it's it's tough because everyone's
going to get probably I don't know 10
cents on the dollar maybe less I wonder
if there's a way to do a progressive
redistribution of funds so I just I'm
just really worried about the pain that
small investors feel I think yeah I
think um there's a lot of thought around
that I forget if
if they actually do do this I mean I
know there's a lot of law about like you
can't treat
creditors differently you have to treat
them all the same so I think it'll be
some kind of proportional payback it's
certainly not going to be that the guys
at the top get you know a significant
amount of their money back and the rest
get nothing unfortunately I think
there's such a
small amount of assets that back this
whole thing in the end and that value is
actually declining every day because it
was inextricably tied to FBF it was like
the ftt tokens which now what are those
worth the serum tokens that was his
project or the project they made what is
that worth basically nothing so
you know it's a very it's a hard
situation and you know there's a bigger
ethical concern which is FTX us
it's unclear how backed it was but it
was clearly more backed than FTX
International
do you take all that money and throw it
into a big pot and give people money
back or do you give the US people back
their amount of money which is probably
going to be significantly more and leave
everyone internationally out in the cold
and to add to that ethical issue let's
say you're a liquidator and you're
us-based
there's a tremendous question like legal
questions about you know how do you
ethically do that it's not it's not
clear there's a tremendous incentive to
just favor the U.S people over everyone
else because it's our country America
whatever but um I don't know if that's
necessarily Fair it's it's really hard
it's like it's impossible and some uh I
forget where you said this but one of
the I mean it probably uh permeates a
lot of the investigations you do which
is this idea that it's really sad that
the middle class in most situations like
this get [ __ ] over so the the IRS I'll
go after the middle class they'll go
after the rich is basically everyone who
doesn't have a lot of Leverage in terms
of lawyers money get [ __ ] over
yes and then they're the ones like it's
always the rich and Powerful who get the
favorable treatment as it like a
microcosm of this funny story so
one of the big criticisms of crypto and
I think rightly so is the
irreversibility of the transactions so
if I accidentally send a transaction
somewhere it's gone right yeah so
crypto.com accidentally sent a lady 10
million dollars
and now they want the money back and
they're suing her but the funny thing is
is if you are on crypto.com and you send
let's say I accidentally send you money
and I come knocking on your door at Lex
I didn't mean to send you you know like
uh a thousand dollars I need my money
back
or if I go to crypto.com and I said hey
I sent that to the wrong person can you
reverse it they'll say screw off no way
if I go to court they'll kill me in
court because they're going to go look
this is how the blockchain works but
then they do it they do the exact same
thing they send this lady 10 million
dollars they're suing or no they're
going to win now it's now what's in
court is not whether they get the money
back it's should she be liable for theft
I believe so
and that's in just another case of
the same rules apply differently to
different people whether you have the
money to back you or not it's a very sad
thing and that's why I think people like
you need
journalists fighting for
the little person
we really need it and it's kind of like
this unfortunate thing where that's the
most risky thing to do like legally you
should not be doing that but
um I think it's important to do it's the
ethical thing it's the right thing to do